we're going to begin this hour with a
conversation about policing in America
following the death of Tyree Nichols as
you heard there are a lot of people who
want change with us now are Keith Taylor
or former assistant commissioner of the
NYPD who now teaches at John Jay College
of Criminal Justice and Alexis Hogue
forger she's a former civil rights
attorney and federal public defender in
Tennessee she is now co-director of
Brooklyn law school Center for criminal
justice we welcome you both to the table
this morning I want to know what struck
you most about this case Keith you go
first and then Alexis please outrage
absolute
unbelievable that such inhumane
treatment
would be
would be conducted by professional law
enforcement officers it really really
was awful to to the discipline yeah he
has a retired officer yourself yeah
exactly it's it's painful
um what what we heard and then what we
saw if we chose to watch was the
devaluation of black life yes at the
hands of black officers in a majority
black city was that surprising to you
Alexis it wasn't it wasn't it was not I
know law enforcement and I know my
colleague can speak to this is premised
on control subordination and violence
these are tried and true tactics
regardless of the race of the individual
officer and Society at large carries a
presumption of dangerousness and
criminality when it comes to
encountering black people and again
regardless of the race of the individual
officers this is what they see when they
see a black motorist yeah Ben Crum said
he's been saying all weekend that it's
not really about the color of the
officers it's about the color of the the
person that's being pursued exactly but
I think many people black people in
particular thought did you not see him
as your brother as your cousin as a
nephew I think many were struck by the
inhumanity of how this man was treated
by anyone
there was a form of presidents that
trust but verified you can have the best
wishes or intentions for situations but
you need to have accountability measures
they have to be strong as Americans we
should be outraged that American
citizens are subjected to this type of
treatment there is outrage there's also
body camera footage and there is in
other cases as well and yet the body
camera does not seem to restrain people
in all cases so we come quite quickly to
the question of what do you do to fix
policing given what you're describing
when it comes to the the person that
they encounter the thoughts in their
minds how do you fix the culture of
policing this was a perfect example of
how an intervention like body worn
cameras which are conversations
happening all over this country as a
type of Reform don't actually work these
officers knew they were on film from
their dash cam from their body Cam and
from the aerial cameras right and so it
did not prevent any of their unlawful
conduct making commands that they knew
Mr Nichols couldn't comply with comply
with with even though it was all on film
and so my
um my really strong sentiment is that to
decrease violence between law
enforcement officials and the public is
to decrease the contact and intervention
that police have with the public fewer
traffic stops exactly they don't need to
be police do not need to administer
stops in in basic traffic violations I
know all of us I can confidently say
have engaged in a minor traffic
violation
and to be pulled over and and told to to
get down on the ground and to be
immediately tased we don't need that
level of escalation from an armed police
officer it's not about training and who
was hired for this job exactly that
doesn't that matter the Memphis Police
Department is a department that has been
under federal court monitoring since the
late 1970s providing violating the
rights the civil rights of memphians doj
has had
um and the federal court issued a
consent degree in the late 1970s there's
been continuous federal court monitoring
this is a department that is engaged in
de-escalation training
Chief CJ Davis first black female police
officer came in on a wave of reform
but where was the de-escalation then
yeah Keith you're a former NYPD officer
why do you think after all that the
other First Responders and even the
police officers themselves failed to do
anything to help him once he was where
they wanted him to be because often uh
in situations like this if you intervene
then you may be seen as someone who is
not part of the team is that right by
other police officers or are there First
Responders
so national standards would go away it
would go a long way towards uh making
accountability the priority of police
leadership regarding how these things
happen to begin with and with the George
Floyd policing George Floyd policing act
and it's I really think Keith they
didn't want to intervene because they
didn't want to seem like they weren't
part of the team or do you think that
they agreed in what was had they agreed
on what was happening I don't know
exactly what they were thinking but it
could range from indifference to
agreeing with but one of the pieces of
pushback on the George Floyd policing
Act is that it changes qualified
immunity which is what protects officers
when they do something that they get in
trouble for uh and and some say if you
take that away we already have a
recruiting issue in policing we already
have a morale issue if you take that
away you're going to even have a worse
recruiting issue
accountability standards should not have
anything to do with recruitment you need
to hold individuals accountable when
they have awesome responsibilities over
communities especially communities of
color and poor communities which have
dealt with the brunt of police
excessive force and Corruption for many
years
it it is incumbent on our elected
officials to do their job and to figure
out how to get legislation passed that
makes meaningful change to to these
police departments across the country
Alexis Ben Crump in the last half hour
call this a watershed moment in policing
do you agree indeed and we had a
watershed moment just two years ago two
and a half now with George Floyd's
murder and we saw the swiftness of the
video release we saw the swiftness of
criminal charges and indictment a trial
this was a new wave and we've turned a
corner but I I don't want to live in a
society in which we're just quicker to
respond after violence has after lethal
violence has happened I would rather
prevent that lethal violence on the
front end yeah all right Alexis Hogue
for drawer and Keith Taylor thank you
very much for being here both of you
appreciate it